amen fois avec mon [__] tu laissa
filer marty si je viens de voir parce
que lui il a aucun rapport avec toutes
ces conneries il écrit juste un film
c'est vrai comment s'appelle cette
psychopathe
j'ai pas envie d'un énième film avec des
excités de la gâchette j'ai surtout
envie d'un truc qui parlent d'amour
qu'elle un bébé bien tant mieux on n'a
pas fait une super gars contre voit une
certaine époque et de paix apès pour les
[__] tu sais comment je vois ça ça
pourrait commencer dans la traque tard
une pure histoire de vent
hahaha
ça va pas on dirait une petite nuit trop
cuite casse toi pauv con
pourquoi je sais pas chez martin ce que
tu es une conne billy
allez les marolles r non mais j'ai un
flingue je m'en branle
j'ai toujours aimé venir glisser ses
membres à manier je refuse que tu colles
cette image dans ma tête est de 2 c'est
vrai qu'elle a quand même perdu mon
petit chien ça va forcément mal se
terminer c'est obligé à tous les
psychopathes ou déranger tant mieux si
votre histoire est assez jeune
bizarre en quoi l utiliser dans notre
fils
garde la foi en jésus-christ notre
seigneur et ne donne surtout aucune
information assez de mange merde ne dit
rien